歡迎收聽趙華與古惑仔第1140集
今天是2026年的7月16號
今天是一個很特別的日子
不只是台積電在開法說會
今天的古惑仔是有影片版的
而且今天我請到了一王一后
哪一王哪一后呢
我前面前言先不講
我先把名字爆出來
第一位是我們的AI達人蔡明翰
趙華婉婷
請觀眾朋友大家好
她給我爆雷
第二位就是我们的PCB女王婉婷
嗨 赵华 嗨 明翰 大家好
因为今天是个大日子
所以我前面前言先不讲
先介绍来宾
刚刚明翰还愣一下
对 我本来想说应该是
Lady First
应该先介绍婉婷
但是因为我讲了一王以后
我没有讲一后一王
所以就只好先从明翰介绍起
为什么今天这么大的阵仗呢
当然是因为这段时间
我想头儿朋友一定内心有点压力
今天台积电开发说
今天在现货市场台积电是红盘的
可是呢
整体的中小型股的体感
还是非常的不好哦
所以一次请来两位重量级的达人
好好的来帮大家
送信心也好
拆解基本面
还有法人的动向也好
希望大家能够对这段时间的变动
心里面能够更有一个底气在
因为像今天
以这个PCB女王在嘛
铜箔基版
台要打到底听版
载版的南电本来很强
今天也达到跌停板
然后有很多人就说
旧旧金像店啊
金居怎么了
好那看到明汉大家也要说
不是讲说7月还有好行情吗
可是好像AI股现在
并没有说太多的利多支撑
他们继续往上走的一个态势
其实最近的国际股市有一些动荡
明明感觉上也拆弹
例如CPI的年增率并没有很高啊
还越减了
所以本来想说
美国升息的状况应该可以压下来
然后韩国今天下午他们也要开会
因为韩国已经很严重
韩国有很多人已经想不开了
去杠杆到他们的政府觉得很严重
可能要来开会
也以为可以拆弹
可是今天的记忆体还是一个暴跌的状态
所以到底这些风风雨
要什么时候才能过去
还有台积电已经公布了第二季的季报
可能可能看到毛利率只有67.7
大家好像不满意哦
所以台积电不但杀尾盘
夜盘这个所谓台积电的ADR盘前
已經又開始繼續跌好 這些事情我們到底怎麼來解讀我們一項一項來好不好好 我们先从总体环境好不好两位都在 看两位谁要翻个零吗按下去
好 第一个当然是总体环境
我们都觉得既然CPI6月没有报表
感觉上美国升息的压力应该解除了
再来就是南韩的问题
南韩现在看来他们要紧急开会去解决
去杠杆去到好像大家皮都脱掉的这种问题
这样的国际事件的干扰
到底什麼時候可以告一段落
或是其實根本已經不用在意了
其實CPI就是比較好
這件事情是好事
但是因為最近美意戰爭又開始有一點紛擾
然後油價又重新上去
所以如果大家看
因為其實CPI它是一個當下的值
就上個月的值
所以我反而會開始思考說
那下個月的CPI
MON是不是又會上去
對
所以這個暫時可能開心一兩天之後
你又要開始擔心下一次
然后再来就是美债殖利率也反弹了
所以升息预期这件事情又会重新被讨论
这个我觉得还是对盘面有一点点小小的影响
但坦白讲我觉得最近盘面总经的干扰性并不重
对 我觉得AI的杂音啊
然后第三季业绩的订单的杂音啊等等
反而是真的很多 超级多
对 今天可以好好来聊
好 所以等一下来聊第三季的杂音
那明汉这边怎么看呢
我看法還是我也是不變
我覺得
我個人看法我覺得
沒有利空
完全沒有利空
基本面完全都不變
應該這樣講第二季
股市不斷漲
大家都覺得很樂觀
七月到現在
應該這樣講
七月的基本面
跟五六月有什麼差別
答案完全沒有
只有更好
完全沒有任何修正的地方
所有講的我個人覺得
只有一個最大的利空
就是漲多
這是不真的事實
就是結論
上半年指數能夠漲超過五成
那應該說重點是在第二季
一季就可以漲超過四成
指數漲一萬四千點
這是一個不可思議的數字
所以你必須得付出代價
那結論而言
常常講的就是
我跟大家聊天
他會講說
其實台股最近也對比來講還不差
因為對比韓國
韓國比我們更慘
那對不對
我說一分錢一分貨
你要知道
在上半年在漲的時候
廢半跟這個韓國漲了一倍
我們只有他一半
所以就漲的時候我們只有它一半
在跌的時候我們也只有它一半
是一個非常合理的現象那我們現在壓回感覺有壓力你要思考一下韓國人的壓力一定是我們兩倍大這是可以直覺想像
那我會覺得最後我常常講
不要看著股價去影響心情
因為現在7月的架構跟第二季
是完全沒有任何改變
我看到只有更好的數字
幾乎沒有數字出現任何的惡化
那大家在講韓國的事情
我的結論就是
大家要有一個概念
就是我自己賭
就是我不是因為台灣人
就是說如果今天韓國股市跟台灣股市
一直爆到明年底
我還是覺得韓國漲得會比台灣多
這個架構是不會改變的
他們主要只有兩大低潤廠所帶動整個時速
這兩大低潤廠
因為這兩年的獲利持續
本土現在本益比連10倍都不到
台積電本益比真的也很低
但畢竟還20幾倍
所以韓国现在最大的问题
就是涨跌速度太快
所以你涨的速度太快
一拉回不好意思
就是你有杠杆的人都得付出代价
那你没杠杆的
其实未来一定还会再往上
现在就是把那些
当时压的太满的人全部洗出去
未来还是会走高
所以回过头来
无论韩国台湾或背半
其实这个趋势
第二季唯一的弱点
就是真的涨的速度太快
那基本面大家现在就会放大检视
那我個人覺得記得基本面不變
不要永遠用股價來說話
那數字只要能夠持續往上
都要維持樂觀
因為第二季的話
我們相信季報的狀況一定很好
等一下也會來幫大家做一下搶先報
可是最近韓國人有一個說法
他們很羨慕台積電
他們說你看海力士跌成這樣
然後三星跌成這樣
人家台積電是撐在那裡
不過呢我們是不是自己
不認識自己台積電有多好
因為就在我們錄音的同時
台积电就公布了所谓第二季机报
现在正在开发说
目前听到的是资本支出
要上调从560亿美元
现在要上调到600亿到640亿美元
这可能是对设备厂的一个好消息
但是你可以看到台积电的盘前还是在跌
尤其是今天一公布之后
台积电的期货就直接杀尾盘杀到黑
到底怎样啦
上半年赚50.05元EPS
三绿三升在第二季
请问到底有什么不开心吗
還是市場有什麼樣的誤解
也許晚上美股ADR那邊開盤的時候會有不一樣的想法台積電其實我覺得應該是過去這兩三週之前大家對於毛綠的期待性太高對 然後公告出來其實這樣67.7滿好的
但是因為法人圈已經樂觀先預期了
所以變成稍微有一點點不如預期
然後另外一個我覺得還有就是
其實大家會害怕
因為這幾天公告的財報
過去這兩三週財報從美光
然後到那個韓國的
其實三星
公告的財報都非常好
可是然後展望也還OK
但是後面都傻
所以大家就會覺得利多不長
很怪
所以我相信
也一樣會害怕說
明天會不會台積電也利多不長
它其實剛剛公告
不論是資本支出
跟全年的營收展望的目標
看起來都是上修的
所以也是很好的
所以其實我也認同明翰講的
基本面尤其是AI這塊沒有變
但是裡面可能變的是
其他的東西
或者是大家擔心
會不會現在看到的沒有變
未來會變
對 因為我覺得股價有時候反映的是
市場預期這件事情
那實際值可能沒有動
但是預期在波動
所以股價才會上上下下
對 所以這個預期是
我們可能要去拿捏的東西
好 是因為預期嗎
是因為市場
因為剛剛明翰看到我
就跟我說哪裡有不好
哪裡不好
我說我覺得沒有不好啊
我這樣講
有沒有好
我觉得好或不好
你不要等到看到股价
不要看到股价
不要看股价就去解读
因为其实我们还没开的时候
我就有一个表格
就是你后面
公司原本的时候
把大家已经有期待
再把开出来的数字填进去
其实结论就是
它的数字其实都是
应该这样讲
公司给的区间的上缘
几乎都有达到
无论是营收 毛利率
各样的获利
获利最后是超标
那你最起码的营收毛利率
其实都是公司给的区间的上缘
那你说很多人期待更高更高
那只是市场的传言
真正看到外资比较
等于说法硕会前
这个礼拜几乎每一家都有出报告
大家给的这个毛利率
也都落在差不多公司的上缘而已
所以也没有人敢真正的大行
敢预估毛利率预估七字头的
其实也没有
那都是市场的传言而已
所以我常常讲
不要去看因为股价跌
或换个角度讲
其實這個公司
之前就有提到下半年的毛利率
他們壓力會很大
他也講了很清楚
兩個因素
一個就是二奈米
另外一個是海外的擴產
所以他下半年毛利率他也講得很清楚
就是2-3%的一個壓力
那2-3%是一個很誇張的數字
對他們來講
那但是呢
這個我剛
我那時候看這個禮拜外資出的報告
其實就分兩派
一種呢就是有聽話
就是下半年的毛利率有稍微下修
但是幅度沒有公司講那麼誇張
可能就是往下掉個一個%
另外一派就是不信邪
就是覺得還會繼續往上
然後就持續往上拉
上拉
但是幅度也不敢拉太高
因為公司畢竟就是講會往下
那目前看起來就是
我個人覺得以這個架構
應該要記得一件事情要對比
不是說大家的看法如何
你要講
這個是連續劇的問題
公司之前怎麼講的
以現在公司的說法
第三劑對第二劑
大致上就是應該說
這個區間的range
有稍微掉一點點
一個Percent左右甚至不到
可是上一次法說的時候
我稍微提到下半年
因為這個產能開出會掉2到3
所以代表的其實就連續劇的角度
現在是持續在上修當中
所以結論我常常講的
你必須要以前他的說法
到一直到每一季的角度
持續的關注
那另外就是
這個在法縮會前或看到股價之前
你先把數字寫下來
出來結果是如何
又預期就又預期
現在反應的不是他基本面
你現在反應的是市場的情緒
但市場情緒是來得快又去得快
你現在市場稍微悲觀
你就跟著殺
過幾天大家樂觀
你再追回來
我覺得這個老實講
不是操作的方法
不過這一次台積電在法術會前
是相對沒有跌
因為大盤的狀況不理想
中小辛苦的狀況不理想
台積電的沒有跌
感覺就像反向來說
它已經算厲害了
對 有這樣的一個感受
可是我個人覺得
就換個角度講
就剛剛趙華提到說
韓國人很羨慕啊
所以你看人家台積電
我就說
第二季的時候
你抱著三星 海力士的時候
你有沒有羨慕台積電
第二季漲都不漲
你的股票標翻的時候
你有沒有羨慕台積電
不是等到你的標翻了
然後開始坐頭往下的時候
你就羨慕那個
之前沒漲的開始補漲
這個概念是不對的
結論就是台積電第二季
是明顯落後
不要說比韓國
它比起台灣它就是落後
對不對
那最近為什麼能抗跌
它就沒漲為什麼會跌
這概念嘛 對不對他沒漲現在在殺的都是之前漲很多無論尤其是两种一种就是业绩没有改善但是股价明显比业绩强
另外一种就是根本没业绩
纯粹是认为明年会有多厉害的
现在开始修正
当然我也老实讲
有部分就是也有获利
最近也跟着往下拉
但是重点都是大家毕竟位线高
可是台积电是不争的事实
就是本益比二十几倍
对比韩国是高
但對比台灣的AI股它真的是便宜
另外一點呢就是它第二季沒漲
所以現在開始慢慢轉腔
我覺得是合理的現象
所以我覺得重申就是不要
應該是把那些漲很多的這個個股
你可以稍微去減碼
反而GEO然後呢
漲幅相對比較落後的族群
所以我覺得反而是目前布局的方向
好但是現在布局的方向
其實蠻吃力的
必須講兩位達人
这个各自有自己喜好
还有就是看事情的方式
例如说像前一阵非常夯的被动元件
明翰就三番两次提醒说
因为被动元件在营收的成长率上面
比较跟不上股价的涨幅
一定要趁势做
如果反转千万不要一直去减
这件事情在最近就验证了
如果中间国具破1000就想减
破900就想减
那可能现在就是真的非常非常的痛苦
这是其一
但是也有看好的嘛
例如说像明翰也觉得修正下来的话
设备股这个有业绩的
这两天有反映到
腿电法朔暖身
风测股也不错
对不对
然后PCB
其实明汉有常常讲
回档要买PCB
但这边的话
就要接到婉婷这里来了
PCB也不容易
因为婉婷有收到那种私讯
或什么就跟她讲说
为什么星星都没有长
我们就吓到说
你要看多长的时间
如果星星是今年以来的话
那长很多
但星星如果是这一个月以来
你可能会觉得怎么搞的
上去又下来
而且输给南店
所以现在的话
两位如果接下来
以股价的位阶
跟所谓即将看到的第二季的季报
还是各自会看好
或是有警讯的产业
要不要各自我们来跟听众朋友分享一下
好
我先讲一下PCB
其实我今天来想要跟大家分享
就是有一些股票蛮常被问
像金像店
对那星星当然也有
星星我就被问到说
你推星星這兩個月都不漲
對 然後其實我還蠻無言的
因為它今年以來真的漲非常多
然後其實漲我覺得股價價格這件事情我沒有很喜歡聊我喜歡聊產業趨勢然後從這個趨勢跟你說他方向變了沒他其實方向完全沒有變對 可是我記得有一集
我來錄完的時候
晚上就有
就是很厲害的操盤人
就賴我說
我今天catch到你在理財達然秀
其實在透露
你覺得
載板會休息
你沒有感受到對不對
很厲害的經理人
跟你同一家
沒有沒有不是不是他已經退他已經退就已經離開了
對然後他就說因為我那時候我那一集的講法是因為不缺
對但是那一集又被別人問說我不是說不不缺嗎
對但我曾經有講過很多次就是不有很多種
所以你要先釐清我今天講的不不缺跟不缺是哪個不不缺
哪個不缺我現在載版講的是踢步踢步一直都很缺
所以我那个时间点讲说
第二季T步很缺
然后大家不够
步不够
所以宅版厂如果买不到步
它出货量无法增加
然后所以它的营收动能只剩下涨价
那只剩下涨价的话
它的动能可能就不够强
没有第一季这么强
所以月营收MOM如果成长性放缓
股价的强度也可能会放缓
然后我们之前讲的这个Rubin出货
会造成它的宅版面积变大
然后供需失衡的再强劲涨价这件事情又还没发生
所以第二季就会变成是一个尴尬点
对 可是我相信Rubin开始出货的时候
他的需求强度会更强
那如果有不
那出货量就会增加
那如果没不
那就是涨价幅度可能会更高
他会去排挤掉
我不想接的订单我就不接
但是我好的订单我的利润率很高的
我就往那边去出
那我毛利率跟获利就会再往上
所以下半年我认为在板还有一次
还有往上的空间
但这个是大方向
我没有特别定义南电星星紧索
对就是一个大方向
那南电星星紧索
其实南电这一波
其实有一段时间比星星弱
是
对然后有一天南电开始比星星强
对
然后就有人问我说为什么
对其实
明亮也有被问
其实一开始是南电
开始可能法人的关注度变高了
可能座谈会啊或什么样的
關注度變高了
然後他在這個漲價的解釋上比較積極
對 然後再來就是星星他有發DR他有募資的動作那有時候募資的動作其實對股價會有一點暫時性的干扰然后这个跟基本面其实没有关系对 所以这个就回到刚刚就也是明汉讲
或者赵华讲
就是其实你反而要去思考一下
现在南电短期上涨那么多了
会不会其实你要再做一下调整
而不是去追涨很多的
因为其实这三档的方向性
在载版上都是一样的
那最近载版性的议题是
因为ABF太缺
然后BT大家就不想做
因為BT過去的利潤比較差
所以大家開始減少BT的生產
然後去做ABF
可是相對的
因為BT的供給減少了
然後BT誰在用
記憶體在用
對 所以BT又瞬間漲價漲更多
這件事情很有趣
就是大家調來調去
反正就是我要產能都不夠
我要追逐最好利潤的東西
然後所以最近的議題
就是BT多的人
可能反而漲價的幅度
在第三季會變好
緊碩嗎
對
所以很有趣
就是本来ABF很好
就没想到BT也跟着好
但之前有一个传言说
三星说我不要让BT涨价
就这种鬼故事在市场上
真的是时不时就会传出来
对
那个时候其实也有短暂性的
对台湾的宅版场有点点干扰
杂讯上
可是我那时候背问我就说
我从来没有听过
韩国的宅版场在全球PCB版场前十大
所以
他没有那么重要
他被砍价可能是因为竞争力的关系
他竞争力不够强
所以他必须要被迫他的客户
就是示弱
那台湾的竞争力都比较强
所以我觉得不能相提并论
好 这个是在载版的部分
我们顺便把同伯基板也讲一下好了
因为今天台药叠听版
台药的修论幅度看起来是比较惊人的
本来一度就觉得要2000
就现在已经变1300
那台光店从六字头6000多块
因为它营收创历史新高那天
有大涨
就现在变4000多块钱
所以铜箔基板没有不好
也没有没涨
可是每次一修正
大家的感受就是
是不是已经涨太多
涨完了
有这种的反应跑出来
我先从产业面的角度来看
其实第二季铜箔基板涨很多
所以大家的财报都会非常好
然后第二季主要铜箔基板
在拉货的是AWS的Trainian 3
那主要供应商是台湾跟台药
所以也看得出来他们的业绩很好
可是如果是就法人的角度来看
法人會一樣大家會去買比較
就是最近期看起來有變好的低基起鼓
然後偏偏最近有連貿公告了五月份字節
那個毛率跳了十個百分點
然後再來就是南亞
因為低階的就是一樣嘛
大家高階的產能不夠
然後所以就全部不願意去做低階的
那低階的沒有人做
反而就漲價
所以南亞也瞬間受賄
然後再來就是南亞今年也很積極的去送高階的東西
她目前是送驗證中
可是過去她速度沒有那麼快
所以光是他送驗證的速度變快這件事情
市場就願意給予他一定的評價
所以南亞過去的評價很低
那他現在被re-rating了
所有的股價行為在re-rating的那一段
就是本一筆跳升的那一段是漲最快的
所以法人其實最近在做的動作是去買南亞
然後去調節部分的相關CCO概念股
所以單純就是有一點籌碼挪移的概念
是
好 所以就是大家呢
一下缺這個就覺得我要生產那個
然後又變成缺那個
有點像是不管是資金的籌碼
或是產品線
大家再輪來輪去
可是整體來看還是一個持續向上的態勢
其實我覺得也可以從籌碼的角度來看
假設我就是只有一百塊
我本來只賣兩檔
那我現在變成買四檔
那我就我錢不夠啊
我只好賣台光賣台藥
我要去買南亞
那其實同樣的概念
你如果就像過去這段時間
四五月為什麼漲那麼多
因為大家都融資去買韓股去買台股
所以我們兩個股市這麼熱
然後當你四代同堂六代同堂
然後主管機關開始警示的時候
你的水就是你的100塊
你沒有辦法變120
你可能變90
那大家都要去槓桿的時候
股價就自然而然會跌
有時候真的不是基本面的問題
是 好
因為明漢剛剛也特別講了
他覺得基本面上沒有什麼樣的問題
但是各產業在你心裡面的評價
是有很大的差異
對應該 我個人覺得啦
反正區分
我覺得每一次
不要看著新聞去做股票
不要看著新聞認為說到底好不好
其實數字會說話
因為畢竟這個都已經整年度過了一半了
我剛剛講你不用看
甚至根本不用看獲利數字
光看營收
每個月看一下營收的表現就知道了
那我剛剛講的第二季
漲很多族群確實就是數字沒有那麼好的
那回過頭來PCB
因為剛剛婉婷在
所以我這細節不講反正只有一個重點就是你可以看一下PCB當然不是所有的個股都好 沒錯但是代表性的個股包括CCL 或者是講ABF
幾乎每一檔營收其實都是非常好的
那我覺得要追蹤的部分
你要把心思花在
我常講把心思花在基本面
不要把心思放在股價上
股價不是你決定的
你不是今天跌就怎樣
不是漲了怎樣
心思怎麼可能不放在股價上
我覺得這邊代表庸俗的
代表就是由我本人
可是你如果很在意股價會發生兩點
第一點你會很緊張
第二點一點幫助都沒有
就是這樣子
因為但實際上我常常講
如果今天基本面
你就比如說我結論而言
比如說這半年來他都很強
到最近數字開始不太對
那你是不是考慮要減碼
我覺得這個合理
可是如果數字現在營收功夫
他還在創高
尤其最近很多營收創高的個股
反而是跌的 沒錯
對吧 那這時候你就開始解釋什麼
利多不漲 你到時候下車過一段時間
又轉牆 你又得追回來
我覺得故事不斷重複
或者是說 AI這兩三年的進程
其實有一個很大的重點
就是因為畢竟已經兩三年了
現在不可能有機犬升天
就是醒來每一天
整天所有的 AI 股突然都噴出
那個環境已經不存在了
現在只有一個健康輪動的時候
畢竟我個人覺得你會講PCB
你把時間放長一點
以這一兩年來講
PCB算是AI組織裡面
搶走很大很大光彩的一個區塊
真的是長得非常非常多
總是該休息
我們回過頭來
從上游的晶片到封測到散熱PCB
然後甚至到我們講的機殼
到最後組裝
我個人覺得可以抱怨
大概只有組裝可以抱怨
因為他數字真的
他數字真的很好
但他真的一直沒輪他
其他的我舉個例好了
機殼之前人家一直問
飞渴業績不錯
我說我也不知道
你只能等
結果等到川普轉強
每個人都說川普有多好
那之前半年前
他業績也在創高
股價就整理
甚至逆勢走跌了半年
你可不可以撐得過去
那最後就轉強了
那現在我剛剛講PGP
畢竟這半年一年來
他確實是漲的幅度非常大
我在講白一點
就算休息多久
也沒有人知道
也許一個月
也許半年都有可能性
就算回三層又如何
對 就算回三層又如何
因為確實長的幅度很大
那如果你真的是
結論而言就你要拿捏一下你的位階是在哪裡如果你是很下面那根本就不用理他因为基本面没变那涨多修正那人家问我说要不要先跑一趟
我常常讲
你以前跑了
到底有没有让你赚到
对不对
你跑了最后都是卖飞
那你就算了
那个只是中间震荡了就算了
那如果你真的是成本很高
你自己就要衡量一下
我会建议如果没有杠杆
你真的也不要去看
你现在是亏损多少
我觉得没有很大意
但是如果呢
你以後是高檔買你以後是槓桿
那故事就不一樣了
因為你畢竟就是你一開始就是壓的比較大
那你就要心理準備
如果風險來你就不管賠錢就得跑
那是另外一回事
否則我覺得像這種就是純粹漲多休息
震盪就是呈現一個輪動
但是到底會比如說
人家這時候最安穩
那你覺得要拉回多少
什麼時候會轉強
我答案我也不知道
反正就是輪動
所以最後我常常跟投資人講
你的原则就是你的资金要有效的分配
你不能PCB好
然后你的持股就超过五成
其他都没有
就全部压在一个产业上
然后等到他休息拉回的时候
你又很痛苦
之前爆赚的全部一次回吐
结论而言就是
你所有的资金如果都在AI上
然后每个族群都布一些
甚至我也有
就组装就组装
就了不起一层资金
他放在那边一两年不动
我也无所谓
那我也不知道它什么时候会活过来
那无所谓就是它如果真的不动
最起码我其他的会动
那维持一个适度的一个
所谓的分散投资
但重点都在AI的核心
而且你所有的个股营收都是很强
持续在创高
我就会很确认
你的整体的资产的涨幅
一定会比大盘更强
好 因为虽然
我这边今天要代表散户朋友
虽然刚刚讲到基本面真的很重要
而且我觉得真的不能忽略一个事实
最近我必须讲
大家如果有好好认真
比较中长线投资
叫做获利回途而已
应该不至于说什么变成惨赔
如果惨赔就会像明翰刚刚讲的
可能追高
看到都已经涨很多了
还忍不住追上去
因为明翰刚刚形容说
有人看到星星不会涨
就说那要不要去追南电
结果南电今天跌停板
所以明翰就说
那你看到跌停板还会想要追吗
那还有就杠杆开太高的时候
一个风吹草动压力太大
就只好賣掉
可能是這樣子的狀況
要不然如果以中長線來看
講好的這些AI個股來說
原則上頂多就是獲利回吐不過剛剛明浩有講到一個重點他有說大部分他覺得只有伺服器組裝代工的值得暴運還有我覺得散熱也可以抱怨一下吧
散熱這一波也是重災區
一直都起不來
自從什麼兩片變一片開始殺之後
就一直起不來 建測的部分
那其他的我只能說
像被動你早就提過了
這個可能超長太多
所以回吐個三四層你也覺得是合理的
這裡面到底從現在展望
好 不要講股價位階好了
你覺得價值沒有被彰顯的有誰
就是尤敏漢可以先延續剛剛講的散熱跟組裝
我們先這樣講
散熱的部分
這個覺得說他好像是不是也應該出來喊話
我個人覺得這個是你時間軸的問題
其實我常常講的就是說
如果你時間軸拉長
這個就比如說人家留言問我說
旗虹最近怎么弱
我说结论而言
它从二三年那时候才一百块
如果你要从那时候看的话
我意思说
因为你结论而言
你不能从你的角度
可能你的持股时间
可能是一两个礼拜
可是我是常常讲
它从二三年AI以来
它从一百块涨到两千多
但是要记得一件事
我个人觉得
这个散热
尤其像这种旗虹双虹
这些
旗虹它股价它有个特性
就是说它基本面的一个部分
非常强势
就算他营收創高是說稍微整理
過一段時間他又再創高
但是股價的部分跟基本面
常常會呈現脫鉤的現象
但是我覺得長線是合理的
偶爾真的
應該說营收創高的時候
他不反應
過一段時間整理過後
突然沒有任何理由
他們整個族群就轉起來
就是常常類似這樣的格局
那我常常講這是第二
他有很大的特性就是
我覺得散熱族群
其实如果就AI零属线
如果你真的够存
营收动能够强的
其实老实讲
现在几乎很少低于50倍
算真的是
大部分真的本益比都很高
和散热也才20几倍
老实讲我觉得
都还是有在往上的空间
那刚才提到
他从100块涨到
涨了20几倍的股价
他的本益比还在合理范围
你就知道
他的这几年获利
到底成长了多少
那你如果今天你的这个左眼就是这一两周
那我也可以告诉你
我也不知道什么时候能转强
但是我只能讲最后就是刚刚提到
用整个连续距的角度看到
過去的他過去的紀錄表現
無論股價或者是這個基本面
那一直到最近的狀況的營收都還很好
他股價不漲
那你就沒關係你就等他
因為常常講人家會說
這樣會沒有效率
可不可以搬到更強的
比如說今天哪裡有轉強
我說這個是每個人操作屬性不同的
有些人就是很有能力
每天哪裡強就往哪裡追
塑化牆往塑化跑
今天自行車噴出馬上就卡進去
那如果你有這麼能力
那當然就直接做最有效率的事情
但我個人覺得一般人是沒有這種
哪裡強 馬上可以卡進去
又馬上賺到價差
又順勢下車的
因為這種人我真的覺得
如果你過個兩三年
你就準備變成首富了
因為如果這麼強
但是我覺得這個真的是少之又少
所以大部分還是要用比較長線的角度
萬一就是沒有盤勢沒關注到
突然殺下去了
你也不用怕
因為你確實就是基本面有做支撐
所以结论来讲
我觉得刚刚提到散热
其实还是一样的话语
就是基本面不变
偶尔都会有留言说什么
散热又什么规格改
最后我常常讲
再来的这功耗越来越高
它的散热越来需求越来越高
这是不争的事实
那常常会提到说
我常常讲有风险在哪里
如果相对而言比较中小型族群
在变化的时候
这个相对而言
有时候它有没有跟上部队
就比较难抓
但你大型的这种所谓的
我们常常讲
如果你今天挥打要改规格
他一定会把这个老大老二拉到桌上来
大家一起想办法去改变这个
不可能不理他自己就在家里弄弄
以后东西要谁帮他生
他不可能去找五家小厂
想办法来取代大厂
这一点都不合理
所以结论就是中间的震荡
我还常常讲
大家有时候害怕的时候
你只要想一件事情
你除了假设你没看到股价
你再去搜索其他的新闻
你會不會害怕
如果你今天害怕的來源
是因為股價弱
你就害怕
那就很容易受到股價的影響
那你就容易在其實基本面很好
然後大家心裡這個可能正在調試
股價正在整理的時候
反而你容易殺在底點
因為剛剛講到很多的傳言
是圍繞在回答對不對
因為剛剛講到的是散熱
一開始就講到
均熱片兩片變一片
就是規格改變
然後說回答的機櫃要延後推出
有沒有然後又再講到板子什麼中介版又不要用 規格要改了所以最近的传言确实围绕在挥达的规格改变或是延后这件事情上面
对
那婉婷怎么看这件事情
因为虽然我们不要看股价
可是说实话
在涨到那么多的时候
这些传言一出来的杀伤力
就是特别的强
对
其实这个就是我刚刚一开头
在讲这个杂音的东西
对
那NVE的话
从上一个季度
就是大概四五月份的时候
我们在讨论说
NV 晶片端 就半導體端什麼時候開始出貨
然後我們家研究員就跟我說
台積電或晶圓電
因為台積電是Foundry然後到封裝嘛
然後測試是晶圓電嘛
他說晶圓電那時候說大概6月份會開始小量出貨
第三季會放量
但最近改了
最近改到第三季末才會放量
所以晶圓電算蠻上游的喔
他如果往後了
其實他就證實了看起來NV有一點delay
對 所以這個Delay跟之前兩週前在講什麼Kyber Delay又不太一樣
所以我們要定義清楚
Kyber Delay這件事情是
應該說今年NV的規格會進入到Rubin
然後明年是Rubin Ultra
然後後年2028是Fatman
好 然後之前呢
就是在講那個Kyber架構是會在Rubin Ultra會上
也就是明年2027會上Kyber
可是在今年初大概23月的時候
其實就有外資寫出來
Kyber會Delay到2028
就是變成從Rubin Ultra變成Findman
所以實際上
上兩週前在講Delay這件事情的時候
就不是Delay
因為大家已經知道很久了
這種東西就比較Delay
可是現在我們看到的是Rubin
Rubin就是最
馬上要出貨的這一代Rubin
好像有點問題
然後它Delay
所以從今天端看Delay的話
整個到組裝段
因為製程很長
到組裝段可能就會有一點delay
那不論是我們講的這個載板的架構啦
或者是記憶體的需求啦
或者是PCB最高階M9這些材料
其實都跟Rubin有關
所以Rubin如果delay的話
其實確實會導致供應鏈的一些擔心
那當然我可以繼續出貨
因為反正最後會出啊
可是投資市場就是我們法人
我們就會先說delay了
那我會不會暫時先不拉
我就會有這個預期
所以股價在反映的是預期這個行為
可是有可能最後什麼事情都沒有
其實這件事情我感受很深
因為我們家應該說去年回到去年來看去年第一季的時候其實Blackwell GB200要量產結果他又Delay到第二季然後所以第一季那時候很多人就覺得
要量產要量產我去佈局GB200概念股
結果三月殺很兇
然後四月剛好又要川普關稅
然後殺更兇
三四月就被抬出場很多
所以我印象很深刻
然後那些三月跌很多的都是MV概念股
結果第二季五六月漲最多
所以這邊如果NV Rubin有一點delay
半導體段有點delay
有些人會開始擔心
林主健的拉貨會不會暫緩
這個是預期
可是實際上有可能不會
那你要真的看到數字你才知道
所以它可能會先跌
跌擔心會拉貨暫緩
然後每個月你發現營收還繼續
因為大家可以囤貨
因為我知道未來需求很好
我知道一定用得掉
我會囤貨
然后所以数字还是上去的时候
你看到营收
你就会再长回去
对 有时候是这个样子
所以如果叠一个预期心理
我觉得写那个报告人
很厉害的一点是
我觉得他讲的事情都是真的
可是是看的角度是如何
我们有讨论过
就例如说
他就讲说矽光子2028才会量产
其实好像不是什么很夸张的事情
对 本来就不是
本来就知道2028量产
大量量产是很合理的
可是他就讲到是
本来好像一副明年就要大幅量产
偏偏它后年才行
或者说机柜的delay
或是规格的delay
这个以前在NV的历史上面太多了
对
那可是一被写出来
刚好股价在位阶比较高的时候
预期心理就让市场有一个共识
是让股价就开始进行一个修正
可是事实上产业的前景
跟大家所需要的产品的规格
是没有改变的
那会有那种规格完全不要用的问题吗
目前没有
目前没有看到什么被换掉或被改掉
完全被取代的
目前没有
所以其实这回来看
就是如果基本面没有变
然后真的不要太
那么在乎的价格
因为有时候价格波动
是我们其实很难预期的
因为筹码我们真的没有办法分析
对
然后所以像最近这样回档
到底回多少要开始接
其实我觉得我跟明翰
我们不会算命
对那如果记书面
两个都常被问对不对
对
记书面派的人
有时候就会说什么
0.382 0.5
对这种算
那你们就自己去看
从低点到高点讲多少
如果以金像電
它從低點上去其實長超多
它這樣回確實也回很多可是其實如果你回個0.382其實它還沒有回到0.5其實這種都叫做一個多頭的修正對那因為我被
我一定得要講一下金像店
然後講一下
因為真的很多人問
對
就我金像店它的基本面
就是它接了各種ASIC的訂單
PCB版
那目前也沒有看到任何改變
它的營收跟訂單很強
可是為什麼它股價跌那麼多
因為它的成本問題在成本
因為CCL第二季漲很多
對 那但是PCB沒有辦法這麼快的轉嫁
所以它必須得吸收
那當它必須得吸收的時候
它可能就會跟我們當初看到的有一點不同的是
毛利率可能會變低 會不如預期
好 所以它財報出來的時候
有可能大家就會下修它毛利率的預估跟獲利
然後 但是會重生看好它
因為它四大CSP的訂單沒有變
對 那股價修正後它反映
它這個修正是反映第二季財報
但是當然要知道這個第二季已經過了
所以它的最後反應可能就是財報公告後
它可能就會立毒出境
立空出境
不過婉婷講到一個重點
這邊也想跟明漢也討論一下
就是所謂的毛利被侵蝕這件事情
因為不只是剛剛講到CCL或是宰版在漲價
例如承受製程也要漲價
先進製程其實大家剛剛看台藝店的下午法術
也在探聽說台藝店有沒有可能漲價
但是應該機率不高
因為它應該都是年初漲價
然後記憶體在漲價
其實這一波記憶體的漲價是最多人叫苦連天的
所以今天的話像又再講到什麼藏心存儲要擴廠
然後說韓國這個李在民要來規劃一個擴廠的計畫
所以記憶體最近的風浪就很大
一方面記憶體廠商希望自己有這個寡占的地位
不停漲價
可是說實話其他
即使是AI廠都有一點受不了記憶體的漲價
這件事情到底該怎麼看
本來我們都受惠於漲價升級題材
可是現在也受害於漲價升級造成的毛利率侵蝕
好 其實我覺得有兩個觀點
第一個部分就是
就剛剛趙華講
這明明到底是利多還是利空
一開始是利多嘛
那為什麼有這個轉變
這就是回過一開始講
到現在其實沒有任何利空
其實就是漲太多
市場氛圍在修正
市場氛圍只要修正
任何利多都會變利空
就這麼簡單
比如說NVIDIA延後
那這也不是說突然有一天就延後
其實這是慢慢的進程
你上個月
我們上次來也有提過
我上次講下半年唯一看得到的風險就是NVIDIA
每次改朝換代它就是我演頭
上次也演頭
延後了半年
所以你真的覺得幾萬個零件組起來
不會有任何有問題
公司給的永遠都是講
沒有任何問題情況下的時間點
可是就上次也是延後了半年
但是給大家看到
過去那半年只要一延後
它股價確實是就是漲不上去
但是也沒有跌
而且回過頭來
台積電的業績也都沒動
代表著就是買不到新的
大家一樣買舊的
所以老實講根本不會有所影響
但是市場的氛圍會受到影響
對結論來講就是
這個漲價到底是利多還利空
其實老師說
如果回過頭來
我覺得要看他的角色
其實前幾天有一個觀眾留言
我覺得他一開始
我覺得他講的內容很扯
但我老實講
我平靜的都想一想之後
我覺得他講的是很有道理
他在講到說
這三家廠
就是三星 海力士跟美光
HBM 他們就閉著眼睛掌
在一個quarter
尤其南亞科一個quarter
它的這個單價就漲了六成
下一季還再漲五成 漲到五法五天
最後誰能來收拾 答案就是台積電
因為台積電很簡單
因為現在他們為什麼半導體能
應該說它記憶體可以這樣一直漲
因為他們全部就是這幾家常
對不對 現在就是供不應求
它就不斷漲
那換個角度講
這間故 這個所謂的記憶體的故事
本來就發生在台積電身上
一直以來這三年從來沒有過
他的供給能夠去配合需求的
所有人都在他家樓下排隊
可是他就是乖
因為他就覺得
我今天是做長期的一個生意
我每年就只有年初
漲那個一成左右
後面就是講不應求
他有沒有跟你講
我每一季漲一成
或者說更狠
每一季漲五成人家要不要拿
還是得拿
所以最後他就說很簡單
台積電就學他們
你漲五成我也漲五成
然後最後需求就崩了
你在看記憶體會不會有人拿
聽起來好像也是有道理
問題就是人家乖乖做生意就不願意
可是這個簡單而言
就是台積電人家走的就是一個長線
人家一直往上走
那記憶體故事不一樣
人家景氣循環
人家悶了多少
你突然爆了
我就跟你講
我就靠了這一次
我就是一次要轉半天
不管多少
只要我敢喊你就得拿
他就是仗著你這個
這個你沒辦法跟他去所謂的
對抗的一個底氣
所以不斷的往上拉但是最終而言我還是覺得最終最後這些厂商最后很容易讲如果讲一个比较严重有点自止恶果
因为你在快速拉高售价的情况下
最后总有一个高点会爆
所以代表着你这整个产业会
最后会下坠的很严重
那你回过头来问我说
这个高点在哪里
我说我也不知道
那我常讲的就是说
就对我的观点而言
我的就認為HBM確實需求就是強
而且這也不是一年兩年的問題
未來就是這樣
所以記憶體可不可以買
我說AI的可以買
因為它就是還在持續往上
而且人家三大廠的本益比十倍都不到
那短線就漲太多有可能拉回
但不用緊張
可是有一個問題就回過頭來
我每次講這個也有人留言說
我就是看不懂
台灣的記憶體
我就說台灣記憶體就是DDR4
所以它就是消費性記憶體
對不對
然後還有一個我剛剛講的警訊
就是連蘋果都受不了
都在漲價了
結果人家把它當利多
我就不了解這個為什麼利多
他的意思說
我們等於說
DDR4這些廠商話語權
現在比蘋果更大
連蘋果都要聽他們的話
我就說對
可是有一個問題
你要知道
他的客戶是蘋果
蘋果的客戶是消費者
消費者可不可以接受你
DDR4繼續暴漲
蘋果不得已
因為他一定得買
你覺得消費者一定得買嗎
我覺得這是很大的問題
最後連蘋果都發生了
代表著消費性記憶體的
這個所謂的再漲價的空間
一定會受到影響
但是HBM它其實
HBM反而漲價幅度遠不及DDR4
因為DDR4就是
反正就是供應
供不應久還在亂漲一通
可是HBM他們幾乎都是長期合約
所以它漲幅是相對有限
這代表著這一兩年漲之後
它未來還有機會再往上漲
可是最後你消費性記憶體
最后终究会遇到修正
但是我老实讲
我什么时候我也不知道
它现在爆价就是高档震荡
没办法有效突破高点
但它也没有再大幅下坠
所以我重申就是
我还是觉得风险还是存在的
因为毕竟我刚刚讲
觉得在这种快速拉升的过程当中
就很容易有出现爆雷
最后整个所谓的
就炸掉的一个状况
那如果要比较安全
这个产业
你应该讲不是不能买
可是这整个故事你要理解
你不能聽大家講就是
這個記憶體未來就是
然後等到炸了開始往下的時候
你就拚命的攤平然後看還有一個問題你一定會看到營收跟獲利數字還是很好這是必經的過程但是你不斷攤平這就是很危險的這一種操作
就是很多的個股
比如說PCB他是慢慢上慢慢上
然後他的獲利上
他的股價上突然有急漲
他在修正
我覺得你拉回是可以持續買的
你就不用擔心
因為畢竟獲利會在創高
可是消費性記憶體
就不知道什麼時候
有可能會出現反轉
你如果真的堅持就是要買記憶體
不是說堅持 我本來就看好記憶體
但是你要買記憶體
就去買所謂的三雄
就是所謂的三星 海力士跟美光
可是台灣人通常有時候
我也不知道
就是他就不想換美金
也不想跨出去
反正就堅持一定要買台灣
我說也不是不行
只是這樣的架構
就得乖乖的去看報價
不要被大家在講
AI需求動得很強給蓋住了
因為台廠生產出來這些記憶體
其實都不是運用在AI身上
這個記憶體的問題
其實我大概幾個月前
我就開始有這樣的想法
就是說你漲到後來
你一定會有一個價格的天花板
因為就像剛剛明漢講說
蘋果要漲價
那一開始不是公布的是他的這個iMac
然後這個平板
還沒有講到手機
結果大摩最近出一個報告說
他預估手機有200塊美元的漲價空間
200塊美元現在台幣又弱
就6000多塊台幣
然後我i17沒有換
為了換i18多了6000多塊
假如真的成真的話
我會拿著那個手機想
這個6000多塊就是裡面那一個
一模一樣的記憶體
對 感覺不好喔
就算買得起感覺也不好
所以我覺得這件事情
它終究會有一個天花板的鍋蓋發生
可是就像明翰講的
我從幾個月前在跟來賓討論這個事情
到現在還是沒有發生
就到現在所謂的記憶體股價
其实还是在高档震荡
但是我也很认同说
如果大家买的是HBN类的
是AI用的
那也许他们常常在讲嘛
美光是不是已经脱离
所谓的景气循环股
因为可以做到高阶的记忆体
我觉得这个是不一样的story啦
那明汉很勇敢
因为明汉讲记忆体
也会有那个记忆体的记忆卡
我很喜欢跟他斗嘴
跟他斗嘴
好 所以现在的状况是
第三季确实可能会有些杂音
而且是预期中的
就是不管說是毛利也許會被侵蝕
對不對
或者是有可能改曹換道的過程中一定會有一些零組件它也許會有一點delay我覺得這個事情我們就看看是不是在現在正在陸續的反應消化中還有就是子彈不要一次打完啦我覺得大家都看好短
就是為什麼會
短短幾個交易日
可能大家的感受就會變得天差地遠
就是真的看很短
而不是看說今年以來
其實台股已經是世界強的一個市場
因為我覺得投資有好多派系
假設你是基本面派系的
你真的不能看太短
因為基本面cycle沒有那麼長
对然后冲来冲去的当然就技术面操作
是
对啊
好所以刚刚从产业的状况来看
那记忆体的话
婉婷也是一样的想法吗
就是说它终究跟这个科技的发展
它要达到一个平衡点
其实我有认同记忆体长到一个程度的时候
是绝对长不上去的
对但是至少短线
今年到明年看起来记忆体的需求
整个需求还是很强
因为整个AI的架构
但当然真的要细讲记忆体
还是要讨论不同规格用在哪里
这个又要另外讨论
可是以大方向来讲
整个经济体现在的供需失衡
我觉得它要看到很快速的价格崩跌
半年内应该不会
甚至可能明年也不会
然后所以可能会维持一个
获利的高档会有一段时间
那我就会回想到当年这个航海王的时代
对其实有一段时间
它是先回报价涨不动
股价会先跌一个报价涨不动
然后后来隔年它会变成
高值利率概念股的首选
所以后来又涨了一段
那如果假设记忆体的报价不再不跌
然后心裁能开出也能有能力不跌
的话整个记忆体的获利还是会有机会上去
所以我不会看得很空记忆体
对但是至少我会觉得记忆体的涨势趋缓这件事情
是下半年会发生的事情
那当然最近也有研究人跟我聊说
记忆体第三季报价只涨十几%
涨幅趋缓
所以以过去这个Commodity的这个景气循环股的概念
他就要开始跌了
他的高点已到
对
然后其实同样的逻辑
你知道我也跟我们家PCB研究
因为现在有交给弟弟看
就给我的徒弟看
然后我就跟他说
那如果有人问你说
CCL股价为什么跌
你也可以回他
因为同样的逻辑也是啊
CCL第二季涨20到40%
有的还涨50%
然后第三季假设只涨10% 20%
那是不是
因为你同样的逻辑
你涨价概念股
你其实就是看
对可是你CCL
你又不会这样分析
对
所以我覺得如果
同樣來看記憶體的話
我覺得它只要報價不跌
因為以前都是
很快的反轉
就是你隔一兩三季後就瞬間的反轉
可是我覺得這一次AI的架構
它的cycle沒有這麼短
然後它的需求增加的幅度太快
所以產能開不出來
所以我認同它到這個地方
其實大家受不了
然後受不了也導致
我覺得供應鏈delay跟雜音的這些事情
也跟這個受不了也有關係
對 可是報價要跌
我覺得沒有那麼快
所以我不會這麼負面的看待記憶體
好 而且總之因為只要有修正後
就事情就可以重新來聊
對不對
如果今天記憶體也修正了三四成的時候
你的故事可能又長得比較不一樣了
所有的跟AI相關的
或是現在在趨勢上的熱門產業
我覺得都是同樣的道理
當然像剛剛講到被動元件
其實被動元件一定有很多人也在問嘛
就跌了
國劇其實跌到快四成了
四成
然後太陽用電影跌了快五成
所以這樣子是不能直接
依我來說
我可能就會先看一下
國際大廠到底只跌沒
因為他們剛好都在7月1號
都其實都有發什麼漲價函啊什麼的
漲價這個趨勢沒有變
但修正的幅度非常的巨大
所以以我來說也先觀察一下
國際大廠如果止跌反穩
也許我們相關的產業就會止跌反穩
那因為資金只有一套
像今天剛剛明漢也講到
一早開盤我就看到什麼啊
巨大美麗打仗停辦日遲
就是那種自行車零組件
痞疾可能就稍微彈來
但是你說是不是太來
我真的不知道
他們真的好慘
就是坐自行車的朋友
在中国大陆的都讲说
哇塞 这是卷到个爆炸
然后他们自己做零组件的都没有办法看好
可是就是跌得非常深
像今天有很多中概股也是相对是大反弹
对 然后像数化股
当然数化股有南亚带头之后
整个台数集团看起来脱胎换股
还有帮员工加薪
然后还有就是一直在宣导
他们现在如何切进半导体跟电子级的商品
整个台数集团动起来也成为避风港
所以现在资金感觉上就是有
稍微從熱門的電子撤出
先找一些地方parking
那parking完之後等什麼
等這些修正差不多
業績又開始接上
開始暖身了
或國際大廠又開始恢復秩序的時候
應該又是一個
重新繼續往上的一個態勢
AI太擁擠
整理一下比較健康
我個人覺得
其實這一段時間
比如說再問說
最近的怎麼量能縮了
然後盤怎麼變那麼正當
今天量更縮了
對 就是說量縮然後盤怎麼變那麼正之類的怎麼變那麼不正常我說現在不是不正常是第二季不正常現在才是正常
第二季那個不可能是常態
我常常要先有這個觀念
股市本來就不可能天天每天開都在大漲
第二季最起碼個人覺得
我在這個
我在應該說可以確認就是最起碼
我在這個市場接近20年
這個絕對是最誇張的時候
通常會有像第二季這種漲幅
一定是之前崩到腰斬再腰斬
才有第二季這種反彈
第二季不是是從歷史高檔開始噴出
這是從來沒見過的事件
那一季指數可以漲超過四成
你就知道裡面的個股
隨便都是幾倍幾倍在漲
那很明顯的資金就是從
一開始大家都先找有數字的
買到那個有進步的
買到完全在原地踏步的
也都買漲了好幾倍
那所以慢慢的自然呢
我剛剛講到這種
這種時間沒辦法拖太長
所以到現在結論就是
台積電法說就是很重要的關鍵點
就是他必須要把扭轉資金
再回到基歐股身上
我剛剛講台積電第二季以來
他的表現就是步入大盤
可是這是一個不合理的現象
因為他的基本面一直往上
對不對
所以代表著最後
大家資金都輪了一圈了
對不對 無論是電子傳產
然後有數字沒數字
全部都漲了一圈了
那你最後就是再回
簡單的就是接棒
再回到第一棒的GEO股
那如果接不上怎麼辦
接不上就得回檔
這就是很明顯的現象
所以現在而言
就是我常講就變成是
如果你手上持有的個股
就是相對來講
我還是從現在
已經不是季犬升天
每天漲的時間點
所以你必須要花一點時間
在這個基本面身上
你說老實講花時間
也沒有花時間
就是你自己手上的個股
你總有一個概念說
他到今年到現在
他的營收到底增長
也不用精確數字
到底兩層三層五層
總要有點概念
不能你自己持有的個股
到底營收怎樣完全不知道
結論而言就很明顯
你是在買一個股價
你根本不認識這家公司
也不認識這家營運
他到底現在表現好不好
你也不管他
你只看他每天跳動
但跳動實際上是全世界
本來就沒有人看得準
說每天怎麼跳動
所以你應該要回過頭來
確認它的
我剛剛講的
反正到6月的營收公佈要記得就是整體上市櫃的營收還在創歷史新高而且年增46%非常誇張不可思議的數字
那累積上半年年增
也超過三成
大概34左右
所以結論就是你自己的個股
如果累積年增差這個
整個捐值太多
然後又漲很多了
那這個時間點你還認為它會創高
我就覺得這是一個很大的風險
那應該說現在呢
在震盪你要稍微做調節
那你可以降持股
或者是你可以換股都可以
可是你要賣的股票
不是那個賺最多的股票
一定是他我剛剛提到
營收我剛剛提到有一個均值三成
你的個股
如果連兩成都不到
甚至還是個位數的
那個就是減碼最好的標的
那至於獲利很好的
我們剛剛講了很多
獲利營收都很好的
可是最近一直在修正
你不要看它技術面很弱
破了什麼線什麼線就要去賣它
其實這個等你賣完之後整理過後
它很容易又出現轉強的狀況
我剛剛聽敏翰講的時候
我就很有感覺
就是大家真的在這種行情
可以多做點功課
不要一直看股價
你真的會很不舒服
你會受不了
然後像我們以前前輩都會跟我們講
利空不跌的時候就是買跌
那現在你會發現利空影響很大
就是干擾太多 就表示
利多不長
對 就表示那個盤還沒整理完
所以我們現在就在家裡多做功課
然後就是包括像明漢建議的做功課方法
或者是我們講的這些產業的選股方式啊
你都先把個股寫下來
然後或者是你去檢視一下自己的持股
對 那我覺得就不要再照鏡的一直想要動來動去
對 然後等到你發現最近報章媒體寫的利空
结果好像都不跌了
然后连续好几天
那你就知道差不多了
这个是一个很好的观察
像我们在4月5月的时候
做第一季财报
然后4月5月营收创新高
很好做哦
你只要表列出来哦
设飞标哦
这些创新高的第一季财报
很棒的就会长
6月就完全是踢到铁板
6月营收创新高
就隔天大跌
甚至跌停板
然后就想傻眼
发生什么事情
6月营收创新高的加速
将近190加哦
這個很驚人的一個數字
然後年增率也非常非常的漂亮
結果常常是營收創新高
隔天半更然後同事說這怎麼解我說我沒辦法解只能說現在利多不反應或是搞不好他們覺得前兩個月反應完了那所以剛剛婉婷講了
如果今天看到的是
某研究機構又出了一個什麼報告
市場理都不理你
那可能就到了一個叫做利空不會反應了
終於
然後呢
有一家營收出來很棒
或是獲利數字字解很棒
或什麼東西消息出來
它大漲
利多開始有被市場接受的時候
我觉得中小型股或热门题材的族群
它就可以回到一个正循环
我个人是觉得不太可能在这边
事情就完全结束
很多人一跌就会觉得事情完全结束了
这个明汉一定常遇到
对应该这样讲
刚刚婉婷讲
其实它是一个观察市场的一个
氛围转变的一个方法
那应该说
但是我觉得投资人应该想清楚
你到底是什么样的人
你是等到市场氛围转加
然后开始转强
你赶快去追
这也是一种策略
但是如果过往呢
其實你追追不贏人家的情況下
現在在市場氛圍沒有好轉之前
現在反而是你一個切入的時間點
所以這個時間點自己要拿捏一下
你自己的平常的屬性
到底是追強容易賺錢的
還是呢這個追強每一次都容易套牢的
去區分一下
如果每一次你覺得要進場的時候
通常就容易反轉
那這個時候就是剛剛提到的
在市場現在氛圍反而比較悲觀
在持續滑落的時間點
我覺得反而是買一點
那通常我覺得這個
最後一定要克服人性
因為現在下墜的過程當中
你永遠都會覺得
明天可能會更便宜
所以你永遠進不了場
這個我常講的就是
你必須要分批
要勇敢的買
因為你不可能
常常講不可能想要買在低點
這是絕對辦不到的事情
你只能買在相對低點
那我剛剛提到現在市場
重點就是基本面沒有反轉
那我剛剛講的營收都還在創高
整個趨勢還在往上
純粹就是第二季漲多
所以現在在拉回的過程當中
所以你應該趁著這個市場氛圍比較保守
比較悲觀開始逆向解讀的時候
去分批布局
那剛剛講不要想愛買在低點
現在這個時間點
只要後續創高之後
現在買都是便宜的
第一件事情要分批
第二你就是要熬得過這段時間
萬一買了
買個兩三筆錢都買完了
他還沒停
那就暫時先不要看
熬過那段時間
後面再講個利空不要理他
我常常講 利空
除了 我剛剛講的
除了政治利空
像當時川普突然拿一塊板子出來
是 是 是
〔此段辨識失敗，約 1:00:00 起〕